This week we're going to talk about about
DNA technology and genetic engineering.
And so this is chapter three of the book.
And uh,
some of this will be familiar to some
of you who've had biology in high school
or other places, you know,
something about Dna. In fact,
if you haven't had a biology class,
um, it's hard to be, you know,
alive in 2008 to not know something
about DNA. It's become such an important,
uh, important part of
our, uh, of our lives.
So I'm going to ask you to, um, to um,
indulge me while I go back
to the beginning and talk
about some things that you
know, but I'm going to go
through this pretty rapidly. Uh,
and I think the book has a
fairly good description of it.
So if you don't pick up
everything in the lecture,
hopefully you've read that beforehand,
you can go back to it afterwards and
read about things that didn't make sense.
So we'll talk about some chemistry today,
what DNA molecules are like,
why they have the behavior that they do.
And you need to understand this in order
to understand how you manipulate DNA.
And so my goal today is to talk about
sort of the basics of the molecules.
They're chemistry,
the function of DNA in cells,
sort of the basic,
the basic side of that.
And then on Thursday we're going to
start talking about how to manipulate DNA
and get closer to using it
in biomedical engineering.
So DNA is a double helix.
You A, you know this,
the double helix was the structure of
DNA was discovered about the time that I
was born. And so it's been
known throughout your lifetimes.
You've always lived with it. But it's
really remarkable how fast, how far,
how fast we have come from just knowing
the structure of this molecule to being
able to manipulate it and
study it in great detail.
So I want to start by showing you this
cartoon that you already know about what
the structure of a double helix.
So it's a twisted ladder and there's a
couple of things to notice about this
familiar structure.
One is that there are two
backbones right here in the,
in the light blue.
So this would be the,
the upright parts of the ladder
that are twisted. And those,
those are two continuous strands that
wind around each other to form the double
helix.
Right?
So one thing to notice is this is this
part of the double helix that we'll call
the backbone. The backbone is
on the outside of the molecule,
like the up right struts of a
ladder on the outside of a ladder.
Right on the inside are the,
are the rungs or the struts
that hold the ladder together.
And there are several things that
you'll notice about the struts in this
particular cartoon.
Uh,
one is that there's four different colors
and so you can see red, blue, yellow,
green here, four different
colors. And that's all there are.
There aren't more than for that.
There are two colors per strut.
So what's linking the
two backbones together?
Our two colored segments that come from
the outside towards the middle and um,
that the color's occur only in
certain combinations. Red and green,
yellow and blue, that's all you
see. You don't see a red and yellow,
you don't see green and blue.
Right. And this is a feature of, of,
of DNA shown in this cartoon a form.
So if you can keep that,
that sort of schematic in mind,
it makes it a lot easier to
understand the detailed structure.
And that's what I want to do for the
first few minutes of the lecture here is
tell you a little bit about the details
of the structure and how molecules fit
into this. This image of DNA that's
already very familiar to you.
But the things that you need to know
are the things that are really listed on
this slide, right? You're going
to know more details about it.
They're not really colors right there,
chemicals but specific chemicals. Um,
and um,
but the pattern is the same.
So the molecules that really make up DNA
are nucleotides and DNA is a polymer of
nucleotides.
And a polymer is just a large molecule
that's made up of repeated units. Right?
And so we're familiar with polymers,
plastics in our daily life.
You know the chairs that you're
sitting on are made of a,
of a kind of a plastic polymer that is
basically an organic chemical that is
cross linked together.
Cross is not the right word,
that is chemically a bonded with repeat
units to make large molecules that when
you have a bunch of
large molecules together,
they have certain physical properties
like the solid property of the plastic
that you're sitting on.
Well,
nucleus nucleic acids of
which DNA as an example,
our polymers of nucleotides and so the
repeating unit in DNA is this structure
here. A nucleotide which
has three different regions.
There's a sugar,
a five carbon sugar,
which forms the core of the nucleotide
and attached to this five carbon sugar at
specific positions on the
sugar relative to this oxygen,
which is part of the sugar
ring is a phosphate group,
phosphate and an organic base.
And when these nucleotides get
polymerize to form a long DNA molecule,
they all get polymerized in exactly the
same way. The chemistry is the same,
is that the phosphate group
of one nucleotide gets
linked to the sugar group of
another nucleotide. And I'm going
to show you that in a few minutes.
So what's going to form the
backbone is this continual link,
phosphate, sugar, phosphate,
sugar, phosphate to sugar,
all linked together to form one long,
long molecule.
And what's hanging off of the side of
this long molecule that's formed by
polymerizing nucleotides are,
is this base unit.
So it's the phosphate in the end,
the pentose that make up the backbone,
they'd make up the upright
struts of the ladder.
And it's the basis that make up
the connecting struts, right?
So the basis or the colors, there
are four different, uh, uh, bases,
which I'll talk about in a moment.
We're going to talk about two
different nucleic acid molecules,
two different nucleic acid polymers.
One is DNA deoxyribonucleic acid,
the other is RNA ribonucleic acid.
And one of the differences between the
two is that the Pintos or the sugar that
makes up DNA is deoxyribose shown here.
And the Pintos that makes up
RNA is ribos shown here, right?
So every pentose in a DNA
polymer is deoxyribose.
The phosphate is linked to
this carbon on the Pantos.
And notice it, there's a number on this
carbon, it's called the five prime carbon.
And this is a convention that organic
chemists use when they're describing
molecules like this,
they'd like to be able to refer to each
carbon separately so they can talk about
reactions with this molecule.
And so the number of the carbons,
and in this case this,
these pintos molecules,
whether it's ribose or Deoxyribose,
the carbons are numbered.
The same one prime to prime,
three prime for prime, five prime.
Those are the five carbons
that make up the Pintos.
So I could refer to the four
prime carbon and you'd know,
I mean this one or the two prime
carbon, I, you know, I need this one.
The ones that are important to us or the
three prime carbon and the five prime
carbon.
And the reason for that is that the five
prime carbon is where the phosphate is
attached.
And Nucleotide,
the phosphates always attached to
the five prime carbon. All right.
And the reason the three prime is
important is that when you polymerize two
nucleotides together and a third
nucleotide and a fourth nucleotide,
when you polymerize nucleotides together,
they get polymerized.
The phosphate of one gets linked to
the three prime carbon of another.
Okay?
No. So this is important
because this molecule here,
deoxyribose is not the
same upside down as it is.
It's not symmetrical upside
down and right side up.
It's a different molecule because the
five prime carbons either pointed out per
pointed down. And so the
nucleotide has a directionality.
There's an up and a down to it and it's
going to turn out that the chain that's
formed by polymerizing,
these has a directionality as well.
And that's important in
defining the structure. Okay?
So these are the penthouses, this, uh,
and remember five prime and three prime
because that orients you with respect to
what direction
the molecules facing.
Now the base is, uh, you and, and we,
you don't need to memorize the
structures of these. I'm going to,
I'm describing the whole molecule to
you in its sort of molecular detail and
then we're going to simplify it down to
a version that we can talk about more
easily,
but to give you all the detail,
there's two sort of classes
of bases that appear here. Uh,
one class is called the Purina and they
have to ring like structures and there
are two of them that are
going to be important to us.
One is Adenine and the
other is Guanine shown here.
And because saying adenine takes a long
time and saying Guanine takes a long
time, we're going to simplify it
by calling adenine and Guanine G.
All right.
The second class is the perimeter teams
and there's three of those that are
important. You're a sill,
thymine and cytosine,
which we're going to simplify
it by calling you t. And. C.
Yeah.
Now remember that there were four only
four different colors in the cartoon of
the DNA double helix that we talked about.
And I told you that those colors
are really represent the bases,
but there's five of them here.
Okay.
There's five,
because there's one of these
that's particular to RNA
only that appears in only
RNA and there's one of them
that appears in only DNA.
The one that appears only
in RNA is you're a sale.
The one that appears only in DNA is,
is timing.
And so in DNA there's only four colors.
There's only four bases.
CTG A and RNA.
There's four bases a g you see.
All right,
so you and t are interchangeable in the
sense that you appears where ti would
appear in uh, in a RNA. And t appears
where you would appear in DNA.
All right?
If I drew this altogether, and this
is one particular nucleic acid again,
now shown in more detail,
the all of the carbons of the,
of the Pintos are shown here.
The phosphate is shown and a base is
shown in this particular base is Adenine.
This is ribos.
So this is a monomer or a single
unit from an RNA molecule.
You know that because it's ribos and
it's the particular molecule that has a,
as it's organic base,
we don't need to really talk about
all the molecular detail in order to
completely describe a DNA or an RNA
molecule because these structures repeat
themselves,
right?
Every unit in the backbone
of this ladder has the same
sugar unit,
the Saint Pintos.
It's either it's either RNA or
DNA and has ribose or deoxyribose.
So you don't need to
describe the whole thing.
You can just say it's RNA or DNA and
you know everything about the Pintos in
every molecule on the chain.
You don't need to say anything more
about the phosphate because they all have
the phosphate,
right.
And every set of these is
hooked together in the same way.
So the five prime carbon has a phosphate
off of it and that phosphate is linked
to the three prime carbon of the next one.
Right?
And they all have a base
hanging off the side.
So the only thing I need to say in order
to distinguish this particular part of
the chemistry of a DNA and RNA molecules
is say it's DNA or it's RNA and what
the base is, right? And that
tells, and if I told you that,
draw me a nucleotide from
RNA that has adenine,
you could go back to this picture
and you could draw the whole thing.
So you can just talk
about it in a simpler way.
You can say a polymer
of of DNA for example,
is four bases long.
That means it has four of these repeat
units and they go in the sequence from
five prime to three prime of a g t,
g.
And if I told you that a DNA sequence
went five prime to three prime a GTC TG,
you could, you could draw the whole thing
referring back to these notes, right?
In fact, you don't have to
draw it this complicated way.
You could just draw it as align,
right?
With a g t and g hanging off of it.
And you would know that that's a DNA
molecule for bases long that it, uh,
right now,
what does the line represent here?
This represents the upright stretch
because on the ladder that I showed you
before, it represents this
backbone that's shown by, that's,
that's formed by polymerizing.
The pentose is together through phosphates
always going five prime to three
prime,
five prime to three prime.
So I could take and draw a
line continually down the
molecule where my finger
was touching, right? My finger
would be touching a phosphate here.
The five prime carbon,
the four prime carbon,
the three prime carbon
and the next phosphate.
Yeah,
so the backbone is what? It's phosphate
carbon, carbon, carbon phosphate,
carbon carbon or carbon phosphate.
And it has this structure
hanging off the side.
Now DNA is a double helix and I've
only shown you one part of the Helix,
right? I've shown you one upright
strut and a base hanging off of it,
but it forms a double helix because
complimentary strands of DNA strongly
associate with one another and
that's a very stable structure.
And they do that because the basis
can interact with one another.
In particular ways,
and this you know about this was the
famous finding of Watson and Crick and
describing the structure of DNA.
And this is what this diagram shows you,
is the forces that hold these ducts,
these,
these individual strands of DNA
into a double stranded form.
And they,
the forces are occur because of hydrogen
bonding between complimentary pairs of
the basis and the coupler mentoree pairs
are adenine and thymine a and t and
Guanine and cytosine GC.
Now,
if read in the book you read about where
this big year is shown in the book,
you can understand more about why these
structures line up in the right way so
that the right molecular
elements are together to form
hydrogen bonding pairs between them.
Uh,
that's really beyond what I'll be asking
you to understand for the course. But,
but you can, you can understand
that if you read it, I'm sure
now it remember that,
um,
that I mean only appears in a
DNA and Duracell appears in RNA.
And so you're a cell can also form a
hydrogen binding pair with Adenine.
Okay.
So the whole structure of a
DNA molecule looks like this.
Going back to a more cartoon
version like I showed you before,
but adding some detail onto it.
Now there are two uprights struts of
the latter one shown in blue here.
The other show in black,
they are linked together by four
different colored segments indicated here,
not by colors now, but
by letters. It's DNA.
So it's [inaudible] and
they always occur in pairs.
Where before it was two colored pairs.
Now as two letter pairs, g c t a.
Okay.
The chains are different
now. They weren't,
they were colored the same.
The backbones were colored.
The same in the diagram there.
Color different here to indicate one
new difference that you know about now.
And that's that there's an orientation,
there's an up and down on the chain
and that's due to the asymmetry of the
nucleotides,
that there's a five prime to three prime
end and the way that they're linked
together.
So this blue chain here goes from
five prime carbon all along the chain.
And there's a three prime
carbon left open at the bottom,
right.
So if I wanted it to link another
nucleotide to this DNA chain,
what would I attach here on the bottom,
I would have chat attached the phosphate
that's connected to the five prime
carbon of another nucleotide,
right? I would link this one.
All right.
Facing in this direction, I
would add onto this, right?
The other chain is facing
in the other direction.
The three prime carbon is up
to five prime carbon is down,
right?
And remember that this molecule,
let's look at the, at the,
at the blue one wouldn't be the same
if I turned it upside down, right?
It wouldn't be the same if I turned it
upside down because the carbons, the, the,
the rings here, the pentose
is, would all be turned over.
The chemistry would look different,
right?
And the sequence of basis
would look different.
The
corresponding half of the ladder
that corresponds to any given ladder,
let's say the black DNA molecule that
corresponds to the blue one is not just a
mirror image,
we call it the compliment.
We call it the compliment
and each strand of DNA,
each polymer of DNA that you could
make or you could draw has only one
compliment. And that compliment
has the following features. One,
it's chain is oriented in
the opposite direction,
okay?
Where this one goes,
five prime to three prime.
This one goes three prime to five prime.
It's oriented in the opposite direction
and it has the complimentary base pairs
at each position where there's an a here,
there's gotta be a t here where there's
a t here that's got to be an a here
where there's,
let's see here at g,
g a c and that's because you
have to satisfy this base
pair matching in order to
have hydrogen bonding in each of the
struts of the ladder in order to form a
stable structure,
right?
If I'm talking about two DNA strands
and they differ only in one or two base
pairs, they won't be exact complements
and they won't form this double helix.
Okay.
This, um, this notion of complimentary
strands is very important.
It's the way the DNA exists
inside the cells of your body.
It exists as in a double stranded form
where every strand is matched by its
compliment. And these,
these, uh, molecules of DNA,
very long molecules of DNA are,
uh,
are condensed and packaged within the
nucleus of every cell in your body.
Every cell in your body has
exactly the same DNA. That is,
if I could stretch out all the DNA
and look at the base pair sequence,
the sequence of basis along all
the DNA and your chromosomes,
they'd be identical in all the cells
may be different in each of us.
And that leads to the difference in the
diversity between people. All right,
and so you, you've heard about
the human genome project,
we'll talk about that a little bit later,
but the,
the goal of that was to take for
a typical human or for a typical,
in the case, the human genome project.
Maybe you're looking at fruit flies.
He went to look at all
the DNA in a fruit fly,
but to look at the sequence of base pairs
that makes up human DNA and write them
all out. Right. We'll
talk about that later.
This slide shows one important sort of
feature of the physical chemistry of DNA
that turns out to be very important for
all of the technology that is built on
DNA.
And it has to do with the nature of this
complimentary binding between double
stranded DNA and the fidelity of this,
of this base pair matching,
informing,
informing stable DNA molecules.
And I told you that the fidelity
is very high. What does that mean?
That only strands that have the exact
compliment can form double stranded DNA.
Because of that,
you can do the experiment and it's a
simple experiment is simple to understand
but,
but the concept is very important.
So I encourage you to think about
it and make sure you understand it,
is that if I took two double stranded DNA
molecules and I expose them to certain
conditions that caused them to denature,
that means it's native
structure falls apart,
nature native structure falls apart.
The native structure is this
double stranded structure here.
And if I heat it up slightly
and I add some bass,
so under slightly basic conditions,
these molecules will fall apart because
you've created conditions where the
hydrogen bonding is no longer favorable.
So they, they, they peel apart.
And so if I had a beaker sitting on the
table here and it contained a million
blue double stranded DNA molecules
and a million red double stranded DNA
molecules and I heated it
up and add a little base,
I'd soon have 4 million individual strands
just floating around in the solution
because I've broken up this hydrogen
bonding and the DNA molecules fall apart
and that's called denaturing DNA.
So that tells you something about the
physical chemistry of the molecule,
that it's these hydrogen bonds that hold
the double strands together and I can
break those down under certain conditions.
If I then if I then put it back
into its original condition,
lower the heat,
say temperature back to body temperature
and reduce the Ph down to seven.
Again,
the molecules will re nature,
they will reform their natural structure.
And for DNA that means forming double
helixes. But they will do that in a,
in a very particular way.
And that only strands that exactly match,
we'll be able to reform their
native structure. Right?
So a blue strand here,
we'll never re nature with the red strand
because their sequences don't match
exactly.
Okay.
But a complimentary blue strand will
always rematch with its with its partner.
Right now this is the basis of a,
of a uh,
physical chemistry process
called hybridization.
And it turns out that this is how we can
identify specific DNA sequences and how
we can do things like DNA fingerprinting,
how we can clone molecules,
DNA molecules from one
organism to another.
Rely very heavily on this principle
of rename duration and hybridization.
And hybridization simply means that
DNA will rename chair and form a stable
double helix only with
its particular match.
Okay.
Only with the hybrid that it
is perfectly complimentary too.
That's something about
physical chemistry of Dna,
what it looks like and how
it behaves in a simple sense.
What I want to spend the rest of the time,
uh,
doing is talking about some of
the biological properties of DNA.
And again, I know this is something that's
familiar to most of you and so I uh,
indulge me just for the rest of
this lecture, I'll go through it.
I want to try to hit the points that I
think are important to remember because
they're going to be concepts that come
up again and again throughout the course.
And I want to make sure
that we're on the same page.
So this diagram at the top here is
a very familiar one to most of you.
It's sometimes called the central dogma
of molecular biology and it indicates
how information flows in
cells and indicates a lot
about the work that is cell
does in a maintaining and recreating
itself and maintaining its environment.
And that is that the
information needed to operate.
A cell is stored in its DNA and that
information gets put into action through a
process of biological
process called transcription,
where particular regions of DNA are
transcribed into RNA and that RNA is made
into proteins and proteins are the
working molecules of the cell are enzymes.
They're structural molecules,
they're proteins that exist
in the membrane that allow
things to go in and out
of a sale.
So really the working molecules of the
cell in every sense and RNA is converted
into protein by a process
called translation.
And here's another picture of it here
showing it a little bit more detail that
you have lots of DNA in each
of the cells in your body,
but you're not using all
that DNA at any one time.
Every cell in your body is only using a
fraction of the DNA that's available to
it.
Cells in your pancreas for example,
or making the protein insulin and
they're making that because you need this
protein.
Insulin is a hormone and it's important
for sugar metabolism in your body.
And so those cells in your
pancreas are making insulin.
That means the gene that encodes insulin,
the sequence of base
pairs that encode insulin.
And I'll talk about what that means
and coding insulin means in a minute,
but there's a gene that tells your body
what insulin looks like and that gets
trans greived.
Okay.
But only in those cells that make insulin
and it gets converted into a protein
insulin only in those cells that are
able to make the RNA that are able to
express the protein.
Right?
Okay.
Well, it turns out that proteins are
essential in driving this process too.
And in order to have DNA,
you have to make DNA.
And yourselves are continually making
DNA inside your body through a process of
DNA synthesis.
And that sin,
that synthesis is occurring because
of the presence of an enzyme,
a protein called DNA polymerase. And the
same way this process of transcription,
which is occurring in cells throughout
your body all the time is made possible
by a protein called RNA
polymerase that allows a RNA,
uh, to be made from a
DNA template. All right?
So it's not as simple as DNA going to
RNA going to protein because protein's
need to be present in order to
make these things happen as well,
right?
Let's talk about DNA synthesis
for a minute. So when a
cell divides in your body,
when cells of your intestine divide,
when cells of your skin divide,
and they're doing this all the time in
order for a cell to divide and form two
daughter cells,
we'll talk about that process next week.
But in order for that to happen,
the parents cell has to copy all of its
DNA in order to have enough DNA to pass
on to two daughter cells,
right?
And it does that through a
process of DNA synthesis.
And what happens is the
machinery of the cell,
largely this protein DNA polymerase is
able to open up the double stranded DNA
to denature it locally,
exposing two strands,
which it then makes,
allows to make copies of.
And what's shown here is what's
called a replication fork.
It's in DNA that's undergoing synthesis.
The DNA molecule here
has been spread apart,
opening up to single stranded Dnas,
which have complimentary base sequences
because they were double stranded DNA.
And then a new single stranded DNA is
formed on each one of these open single
strands.
And so DNA is replicated using one
strand of the DNA as a template,
right?
The result of this process,
if it's replication went down,
the whole length of the DNA would be to
form two identical double stranded DNA
molecules.
All right,
now the book talks about more detail
about this and you can read about it.
Polymerase needs a primer and that
turns out to be important. Um,
and a primer is a short RNA sequence or,
or a DNA sequence that, uh,
gets sort of the, the, um,
the process of replication jumpstarted.
And that's just because of the biological
properties of DNA polymerase at that
primers needed synthesis.
A Co always occurs in one direction and
that makes sense to you now because you
know there's a directionality and the
chemistry is different going one way and
the other and this DNA polymerase only
works on the chemistry going in one
direction and that that and that the
correct a compliment is made because of
these principles of what Sin Crick base
pairing that we talked about before.
It's easy to know what nucleotide to put
in each position as you're going along
and pull it memorizing a new molecule
because of this process occurs this way.
If a parent's cell replicates its DNA and
then passes them along to two daughter
cells, one of the daughter has
one strand from the parent,
the dark blue strand here.
For example,
the other daughter cell has the light
Blue Strand, the complimentary strand,
and each of the daughter cells has
a newly synthesized piece of DNA,
right?
So that's synthesis and that has to
happen in order for cells to replicate and
cell replication is happening
in your body all the time.
Transcription is also happening.
Certain segments of DNA are
being converted into RNA
and whereas in replication
you have to copy the whole genome,
the whole, all of the chromosomes,
all of the DNA contained
in the chromosomes of the
cell in order to completely
replicate it.
Transcription only works on
particular sequences of DNA.
The w the DNA that encodes the proteins
that are important to the life of that
cell. A pancreas cell in
the pancreas for example,
needs to make insulin and so the
gene for insulin is transcribed and
transcription just means making a single
stranded RNA copy of a sequence of base
pairs in a DNA.
I told you that that's driven by
a protein called RNA polymerase.
RNA polymerase is smart.
It knows where it needs to go in order
to make the copy of RNA that's required.
It operates in a similar fashion to DNA
polymerase and that it denatures locally
or opens up the double stranded DNA,
but it's different in that it creates a
new polymer from the DNA template in the
language of RNA using RNA,
nucleotides and not DNA nucleotides.
And the end result of transcription
is not double stranded DNA.
It's single stranded RNA where the RNA
that's produced is called Messenger Rna.
Okay.
It's the transcribed
version of DNA.
Um,
and it's the exact complement
of a particular region of DNA.
Again, more details in your book
if you want to read that. Well,
what I said is not entirely true.
Um,
that used to be the way that we thought
about it, right? DNA goes to RNA,
goes to protein.
That's it.
And that is the way it happens in simple
organisms like bacteria and complex
organisms like humans. There's another
step that we're still only learning about.
Now. We know some parts of
it, we don't know all of it,
but it's very important in,
um, in the biological
operation of human cells.
And that step is RNA splicing
or processing of this RNA,
single stranded RNA that's
produced by transcription.
And we're going to talk more about this
as we go through some specific examples
of where RNA processing is important.
Um,
for now,
just think modifying your picture of
this sort of information flow through a
CELDT include another step that RNA is
produced by transcription from DNA double
stranded DNA goes to a single stranded
RNA molecule and that RNA is processed in
the cell in some way in order
to form message your RNA.
And one of the forms of
processing that happens, uh,
that's very important in human,
uh, in, in human, uh, gene, uh, uh,
expression is that some of the sections
of the DNA molecule are not really
necessary for describing the protein,
the regions that are necessary for
describing what the protein is like are
called Exxon's. The regions
that are not are called introns,
a section of DNA that is
responsible for encoding a gene.
Let's say it's the
insulin gene for example,
might be some stretch of DNA on a
certain chromosome inside yourselves,
inside the cells of the pancreas.
And if it was directly transcribed,
there'd be regions that are important
for making insulin and regions that are
not.
And those regions that are not are spliced
out during RNA processing to form the
Mrf a transcript that's
used to make the protein.
Now there are other kinds of processing
that can happen to RNA as well.
And again, I said this is, this is
really still an emerging science. Uh,
but this is one that's well known and you
could imagine that it's important if I
want to clone a gene from a human right,
if I want to clone the
gene for human insulin,
mean make many copies of the gene
that's responsible for making insulin.
I sh I need to know whether they're
introns, they are not right.
And if I'm going to
make insulin from this,
I have to know that I've got the
entrance spliced out correctly
so that that's something that will
come up in the lecture tomorrow.
So remember that concept and that revision
of this sort of classical picture.
Um, I don't want to go through this
in detail because I assumed that you,
you know, it. Plus,
I think it's a little bit easier to
read and have some time to digest.
But this process of translation
or conversion of messenger
RNA into protein is a
complicated biological process
that's occurring all the time.
Before we talked about how do you
know what messenger RNA to make,
how do you know what, what, what
RNA to copy from a DNA template.
Will you do that by this
Watson Crick base pairing?
So I know if I have a g c g a,
I know what messenger RNA to make from
that because I have to satisfy these base
pairing rules.
It's more complicated in making
protein from an RNA strand.
And that complication is
called the genetic code.
And you know that you probably know that
a messenger RNA is read in three base
units called Code Ons.
And so this particular piece
of Messenger Rna is, uh,
is drawn in this cartoon
in three base pair units.
And that's because every three base pairs
describes an amino acid in a protein.
Okay.
While there are only four different
bases that make up either RNA or DNA,
and so the complexity of an
RNA polymer is limited, right?
It's only got one of four
possible choices at each position.
There are more than 20 amino acids that
make up the biological polymers called
proteins,
so there are 20 choices of each amino
acid at a position on a protein.
Why are there three bases in a coat on?
Because it takes three units where there's
only four choices at each position to
have at least 20 unique combinations,
right?
How many combinations
of Code Ons are there?
If there's three basis and four
possibilities at each base,
four times four times four,
right?
Four Times,
four times four possibilities.
Because I could have a g c
you hear a Gcu here Ajcu here.
Four Times four is 16 if I only had two
per code on, I wouldn't have enough.
Right? I'd only have 16
possible to based sequences.
That's not enough to
specify over 20 amino acids.
If I have three,
I have 16 times four or 64 possible
choices way more than enough.
Right.
That creates a problem in the genetic
code and that there's 64 possible
sequences,
but there's only 20 some amino acids.
So each amino acid can be
specified by more than one code on,
okay.
Right? There's, there's
combinations to spare.
There's 64 combinations of
three of three, uh, basis. Right?
And I only needed to describe 20.
So there's combinations,
despair. So if I look,
this table here shows you how,
uh,
how biological translation takes place.
Whenever a three bay
sequence is identified,
say it's Gcu that
specifies and amino acid,
how would I, how would I know
what amino acid that is? Well,
I could look up this table
because somebody has figured
it out for you. Um, gee,
in the first position, see in
the second position, you in the
GC,
you g see you right here is alanine.
And that's the protein, the amino acid
that's in that position in the, um,
in the protein.
Okay?
So you could read through this sequence
and you could figure out what the
sequence of amino acids would be.
The genetic code is set to BG degenerate
because I can read in one direction.
I can read Gcu is Alanine,
for example,
from this table and if I see a Gcu,
I know it has to be Alanine.
If I have the protein and I want to say
what does the messenger RNA that produce
that protein looked like? I can't go
backwards because there's more than one.
Okay.
Possibility for Alanine, right?
There's four of them right here,
Gcu,
GCC GCA GCG so I don't know
exactly what gene that came from.
I can't read backwards.
And that has to do with the
statistics of this, right?
There's just more sequences in a three
unit code on then I need for the amino
acids.
How does translation occur?
A biologically is shown in
this cartoon here and again,
you don't need to know
the details of this,
but if you're interested in knowing
what's the biological basis of the genetic
code, this is it that inside
cells in your body there are,
there are special RNA molecules called
transfer RNA and they are RNA molecules,
but they have at some
point in their lifespan,
they have amino acids attached to them.
Uh,
for example,
this transfer RNA has a unit here,
g a g at one end of the transfer RNA
molecule at the other end is attached to
the amino acid leucine
and your cells making transfer RNA.
If they make a transfer RNA
molecule that has g a g here,
they only put leucine at the other end
and that's the physical basis of the
genetic code because when a messenger RNA
sequence is being transcribed,
yeah,
one base pair,
one coat on at a time when the sequence
see you see appears in the Messenger
Rna.
That sequence see you see can only
bind with one particular three base
compliment, right? It has
to be the complement. G A G,
this is the [inaudible].
This is the anti code on,
there's only one anti code on that matches
this one and that anti code on it's
always occurs in a molecule that has
losing attached to the other side.
It's a translation occurs by a special
kind of polymerization where these
transfer RNA A's operate by
Watson Crick base pairing.
Okay.
But they bring into
proximity and amino acid.
Okay.
So that instead of forming a new
polymer of a nucleic acid, a polymer,
a polymer of amino acids, is form a
pilar of amino acids is a protein.
Again,
I'm just trying to highlight things you
already know a little bit about the book
describes the details.
Uh,
this isn't particularly important
for us to know, uh, here,
but that messenger RNA gets converted
into a protein of a specific composition
through a biological process
called translation is important.
Okay.
The last thing I want to talk about
today is control of gene expression and
control of gene expression
is a very big topic.
And so I'm going to show you one cartoon
to sort of tell you that it is a big
topic that's really important. And why
is control of gene expression important?
Well, I talked about earlier,
I've mentioned several times.
All the cells in my body,
all the cells in your body has essentially
the same genomic chromosomal DNA in
their nucleus.
If you looked at cells in my pancreas and
sales in my brain has cells in my skin.
They all have the same DNA,
but skin cells and brain
cells and pancreas cells
aren't doing the same things.
They don't look the same.
They don't behave the same.
They don't perform the same
biological functions. Why?
Because brain cells and pancreas cells
are expressing different proteins,
okay?
All the cells in your body have the
capability of making all the proteins that
you make,
but they're not all made in every cell.
Only cells of your pancreas make insulin.
For example,
only cells in your brain make the enzymes
that produce certain neurotransmitters
that are responsible for brain function.
How do cells in your brain know which
proteins they ought to be making and how
to cells in the pancreas know which
proteins they ought to be making?
They do that because they can
control the expression of genes,
okay?
Gene expression for us will mean the
same thing as production of a particular
protein.
When a gene gets expressed that means
it's protein is produced and when we talk
about gene expression,
then we're talking about this whole
sequence of events I just described,
transcription,
RNA processing,
translation to make the protein and so
all those things have to happen right in
an orderly fashion,
in enough quantity,
in order for a particular cell to make
a protein to make insulin, for example,
your cells of your pancreas have to be,
uh,
transcribing that gene
has to be processed,
has to be translated
into the protein insulin,
but that's not all right
that that protein, insolent,
that protein insulin is made in the
form of a long polypeptide that not,
that's not always the final version
of the protein. In fact, for insulin,
it's not the final version of the
protein that comes out of translation.
There are more steps that have to happen
correctly in order for that insulin to
become active.
Those steps are called post
translational modifications.
It's a long word that just means other
chemistry that happens on the molecule
after translation.
It turns out that the
kinds of post translational
modifications that human cells
are able to do are very complicated.
You can do many post-translational modify.
Your cells are capable of doing many
post translational modifications.
Bacteria or simple organisms
are not always capable of that.
Now that's going to be important
when we talk about making human gene,
making human proteins inside alternate
hosts like bacteria that they can't do
all the things that your cells can do.
So how is gene expression controlled?
It can be controlled in a variety of ways.
The most basic control
is by controlling wind.
Transcription happens when transcription
happens and it turns out that there's a
whole biology associated with this,
including molecules that are floating
around inside your cells called
transcription factors and their job.
There are other molecules that are,
that know about particular genes and what
some of the sequences and are able to
turn on those genes inside
cells to make them transcribed.
It requires RNA processing
to happen smoothly.
So if you can interfere
with RNA processing,
you can stop a gene from being expressed.
If you can interfere with this
any stage and RNA processing,
you can stop a gene from being expressed.
And this is a very hot topic in molecular
biology now and human therapeutics.
You've heard about RNA interference,
for example.
And that is the process of stopping this
to stop a gene from being expressed.
For example,
a gene that makes us cell cancerous.
I'd like to stop it from being expressed.
And you could interfere with a
translation by degrading messenger RNA.
For example,
if you had a way to specifically chew
up all the RNA molecules that are
responsible for making
a particular protein,
you could stop it from being expressed
even though your cell is trying to make
it.
So I want you to look at this picture,
read the little bit about gene expressed
control of gene expression that's in
the book. No, that it's a big topic
that we're not going to talk about it,
except we're going to talk about some
examples where GE birth control of gene
expression can be exploited in order
to, uh, in order to treat a diseases,
for example.
So I'll see you on Thursday.